put the kid down dude put the kid down
body camera video allegedly shows a
Florida man resisting arrest by holding
a baby in front of himself to avoid
being tased
[Music]
it happened on September 27th in Flagler
County Florida officials there say a 27
year old man from Palm Coast abducted a
one-year-old boy later using his body as
a human shield show me your fucking
hands dude put the baby down
put the kid down
put the kid down officials say the
suspect Brandon Lee owner allegedly
abducted his girlfriend's one-year-old
son while armed with a handgun he then
drove off with the boy in his lap
I have a Tango deployment
[Music]
after driving recklessly through nearby
medians police caught up with Leonor
near a McDonald's drive-through show me
your fucking hands dude put the baby
down put the kid down
put the kid down body camera video shows
Leona refusing to hand over the child
before he gets tased
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
ER gets back up and runs away from
officers
stop dude
[Music]
he's chased down and eventually
restrained
[Music]
officials with the Flagler County
Sheriff's Office say Leonor now faces
charges of kidnapping and using a minor
as a human shield the one-year-old boy
was not injured in the incident for the
latest developments in this story and
all things True Crime stay with long
crime Network I'm Sierra Gillespie